good
afternoon good afternoon and
welcome I'd like to ask you to please
take your seats at this time in a few
minutes The Graduate School procession
will enter from the rear of the
auditorium and will be using both aisles
if any of the graduates are having
difficulty finding their seats please
ask one of the ushers to assist you
thank
welcome everybody you can have your
seats
now we don't seem to have enough seats
for all the faculty but there are some
seats in the
front you'll be happy in the front
happier than standing I
think uh good afternoon uh my name is
Tom Pard I a professor of molecular
cellular and developmental biology and
Dean to The Graduate School it's my
pleasure to welcome you all here this
afternoon so uh welcome to graduating
students
faculty families and friends uh this is
the 312th commencement of Yale
University founded in
1701 and the 120th commencement of the
uh Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
uh founded in
1892 uh this afternoon we have a simple
purpose to celebrate the completion of
the degree and the advancement of
scholarship and the glory of the life of
the mind on this day those of you who
have Dawn the regalia of master or
doctor stand as a testament to the
advancement of
scholarship and that uh and that very
life of the mind we are extremely proud
of what you have
accomplished uh while you've been here
at Yale and we thank you for your
contributions each to your individual
Fields before we honor you students uh
it's appropriate to begin by honoring
our wonderful staff here at the
University uh we owe very much all of us
to them and what I'd like to do is uh
identify those groups and at the end
we'll have a big round of
applause uh first I'd like to recognize
the University's custodial and and
maintenance staff who make Gale look so
beautiful particularly on a day like
today in the springtime
and
and and and it says here and kept us in
good repair I think the people in hgs
might question that assertion uh all
year
long and let's hold your applause to the
end for the rest of them the
University's dining hall staff who have
are feeding us here at commencement and
throughout the year the University's
clerical and Technical staff who conduct
the University's business and are help
helping to organize the activity here
this after afternoon University's
manager managerial and professional
staff who directed and administer our
departments and who are also helping us
here this
afternoon and specifically and obviously
to the staff of The Graduate School who
you see here on the stage who sustain
our
institution uh in our graduate school so
now for all these wonderful men and
women let's have a big round of
applause
uh finally and separately I'd like to
have a round of applause for our
wonderful organist uh Robert
Benish Robert is one of our uh excellent
students at the AL Institute of Sacred
Music as described in your program uh
this uh is one of the great pipe organs
of the world and so I hope you're
enjoying the music it's producing here
this
afternoon following this diploma
ceremony we will invite you to uh walk
just a block and a half to the hall of
Graduate Studies where we'll have a a
picnic lunch for all of you to enjoy and
to visit with your family and
friends at uh the beginning of today's
ceremony I want first to recognize uh
those uh students and faculty who
received prizes at yesterday's uh
convocation your programs uh list the
student academic prizes and at this time
I'd like to ask all the students who
received academic prizes to stand so we
can recognize
you congratulations on your
achievements uh for the 15th time uh
we're recognizing uh faculty through
graduate Mentor Awards uh these uh
faculty have been recognized that
outstanding teachers ad and advisers of
graduate students uh we had three
faculty uh identified yesterday and two
of them had a chance to speak uh two of
them are here on the stage and one of
them was out of the country and will
address the convocation next year at
this time I'd like The Graduate mentor
awardees to stand see they here
theoretically they're here ah there we
go there's one of
them so now we will award The Graduate
degrees we will call uh you graduates to
the stage U by
Department uh for those receiving more
than one degree the diplomas will be
awarded together uh Dean Pamela
schermeister will read the citations uh
so please come forward as your name is
called uh to congratulate each degree
recipient they will be joined on the
stage by members of their department so
we'll have a little receiving line up
here so you can shake the hands of some
of your faculty as you receive your
diploma and yes audience you may cheer
at any moment that you feel inspired to
do so uh and in in times
past in times past it was thought to be
indecorous for the audience to cheer
individual students but we think it's
cool so uh please uh cheer whenever the
spirit moves
you bean sh
meister for the doctor of philosophy in
African American studies Lamar derell
Bruce Nicole Nicollet
ivy
Brandon Michael
Terry there's a routine up here
graduates that is you stop and you get
your picture taken before you
leave and feel free to come to the top
of the stairs before your name's called
all right for the doctor of philosophy
in American
studies Carolyn Michelle
Crockett Christine Margaret
DeLucia Simeon s
man
Monica Munos
Martinez Madison Alexander
Moore Dara
orstein
for the master of philosophy Allison
Jacqueline
kosi and for the master of arts John
Travis Anthony
sanpedro Lauren Craig
Tilton
right we have to
wait for the doctor of philosophy and
anthropology Alexander
antonides s Suzanna
fata Isaac Thomas
G radika Goen
Janan meanwhile
Ling Hyundai
oan Darian Marcel
Parker Joshua Dalton
rubben
Ryan Joseph
s Shila sesha
Galvin for the master of philosophy
jargalan bur
Toto
Jamie Lee
Inwood for the doctor of philosophy and
Applied
Mathematics rushid do
choy
for the master of arts in archaeological
studies Charlotte Elizabeth
green Benjamin Gordon
King Jane Cosby
Skinner
stevenh Patrick
young for the doctor of philosophy and
astronomy Brook develin
Simmons Katherine Emily Whitaker
teas for the doctor of philosophy and
cell biology Katherine mahela
burn chin Chen
King
Zeba
rinia Emily Helen
Stoops we
Jang
and for the master of philosophy cing
zuo for the doctor of philosophy in
chemistry Brandon Scott
Fowler Christopher Michael
levit Cheryl suy
learn Yang
Lee Lauren a
martini
Patrina and
pellet Katherine Ellen chinopoulos
Philip georgev
shushop
Karen Joanna
young Andrew X
Jang Rebecca Eileen mcis
alred and for the master of science
Candace an
be shuming
Chen Anthony Joseph
Metrano for the doctor of philosophy and
classics
Thomas Hughes Beasley
III lyanna Lin
boychenko Shan Lynch
harrian
for the doctor of philosophy and
comparative literature Martin John
DEA Heather Moore
Clemen Alexander steich
for the doctor of philosophy in
computational biology and
bioinformatics Christopher Ryan
Bolan Jamie Lyn Duke
VJ narima
Garla Hau
ma Simmon
moo
Taio adedapo
toan Mohammad
Udan and for the master of science
joying
turn
yau s
Lee Daryl Andrew
Reeves
guili
zilberman for the doctor of philosophy
and computer
science Aza
abuid
Amai Falcon
aiam antoniio Michael
stules Alexander Leo
Weinberg for the master of science
Justin Pierre
borck Ming
Chang Jun
haa chin
Wang
sha Jing
Wang ad
Jane shiman
Leon
Lou
High suing
law tion
pan
Shan
Ren J
sha Ru
tan eten
Rona muhan
though for the doctor of philosophy in
East Asian languages and literatures
Ryan Marshall
cook Kevin Conrad schonberger
Jr Edwin Isaac stothart V biver
or
for the doctor of philosophy in ecology
and evolutionary
biology Megan Lynn
avolio Richard Charles
harrian
Erica Lynn
Westerman for the master of science
Natalie
pilaka for the doctor of philosophy and
economics prianka
Anan
in no because I need this um Brian Hanny
basa lint
beish Erica Teresa
Blom Yos
andan Rebeca Jane
Edwards Elon Joseph
fold
Melanie Elizabeth
Morton Ted Carl
rosenbalm Raphael J
Santos VIs prier
terz
Alexis Akira
TOA and for the master of
philosophy Maria delmondes de
carvalo for the master of arts Daniel
Kennedy Korea
for the doctor of philosophy in
engineering and applied
science Bona Al
Maria Sha
aan
Margaret Francis
benowitz Colin Brown
Compass Shian
ding
Dominique
Duncan
nuk dor
next Rachel Jennifer
fields
Edward C
Fong Brian David
Goldstein Jared Harwin
gansy d Ina rafhaela
hotsky sha
Jin Nathan K
cup
zangl
melis
Minos Jane wui
muturu Christine Marie San
Diego
Baron
srat Dustin
shinos Laura C
Sema Jenner Marie
Sullivan Leo
Tam Kevin EST
Tang
Chong
yunu for the master of philosophy sashka
dimitria Yong
la
Christopher Daniel
urino Jun way
jum sufan
Zang for the master of science
Yon
gon
Kong
boing UA
ding Dong
Dong John Anthony Donovan
Jr Linda Ellen
Fong Bowen
gong
lehon
yenia Stacy
Kanan Yen
quo
Holly May
lson Shang
xinglu Daniel Logan
McCurry Nile C
Pearson
Kevin Anthony
Rocco pared
SAA young
Shaw Kai Shango
El
Jang Joe
Pang for the doctor of philosophy in
English language and literature Samuel
Patrick
Alexander Andrew Charles
Caris Michael E
Kowski
James Ross
McDonald Neeve Katherine
Cunningham for the master of arts meline
bernardet
metler rant
Sharma for the doctor of philosophy and
experimental
pathology jerich Lynn
brandell Juan
Chang
Ryan Christine
guasman for the doctor of philosophy in
forestry and Environmental Studies k
eisu
Angel
Sue Lee
Jang J Young
Park Aaron Marie Walt
shiing
sang for the master of philosophy Maria
Gabriela Doria
Ramirez namata
kala for the doctor of philosophy in
French Thomas Chapman
wing for the master of philosophy Colin
Taylor
Foss
Elizabeth kinen
hebard for the master of arts Ryan Max
Riley for the doctor of philosophy and
genetics Laura Elizabeth deare
chrisy Len
lamb Sarah Alysa
morlat Natalie Renee
powers
Cornelia Amelia
zorka for the master of philosophy
Beatrice Monica Patria Maria
Bowen Elizabeth Rose
desen
ariona
haali Sarah Gan
cosmesi for the master of philosophy
Laura Beth
Moore Arthur J Jeremy
wisey for the doctor of philosophy and
geology and
geophysics Tyler Rance
Leon Ross Nelson
Mitchell
Karen Anne pachowski
Sarah Hutchinson
bores Joanna
wolf
for the doctor of philosophy in Germanic
languages and
literatures Gabriela
stoa for the master of arts naen
bornhold for the doctor of philosophy
and history
Amanda L
beam Megan Lindsay
Cherry Justin Michael Collings
Deborah blle
Doro ziv
Eisenberg Sarah Michelle fieldston
Samuel Joseph
Garcia Freddy
Gonzalez masato
hasagawa
Rim
kazimi Andrew philli
conob Carmen
Cordic John
Lee
Mary Ashley Riley
Souza Gregory Gerard
Roberts Sarah J
spinner
Lisa an ubelaker
andrad eer
verba Marita Helen
ffbe General for Margaret
Wellington for the master of philosophy
Tyler James
Griffith for the master of arts Pierre
Islam thank
you
Travis Arthur
cook John Donovan
mahair Joseph R malne
Jr
Conrad Andreas
Pier arjon nian
Sho and Marie Adele
Smith Claire Jin
mingon for the doctor of philosophy and
history of art Asher
Anderson Michael J
Anderson
Shir Neeve
brisman Jorge Gomez
Tara Freya thorbjorn
Harel
MAA takanishi
noes Jennifer
Nelson Maria tarotina
for the master of philosophy henria
Christiana
langa for the doctor of philosophy in
immunobiology Joy deep Kumar benergy
Augustine hawen
Choy Justin WMA Alexander
guu Jessica Jane
McDonald
Mikela schulam
Panter Ashley and Marie Vian
milum grela V zukerino
Kat
for the master of science Jeremy Bradley
JX for the doctor of philosophy in
Italian Maria claraa Iglesias
rondina
Christopher
Nixon for the master of philosophy
Eleonora
buonocore for the doctor of philosophy
in
linguistics ariro
Kika Mark Kenneth
Titi
for the doctor of philosophy in
management jungman
Kim Stefan M
lellan for the master of arts Eugene Lee
for the doctor of philosophy and
Mathematics Tyler
Foster you
sue
yq
Kim Miriam lancha
Logan Igor
rapinchuk mial
trinety
for the master of philosophy joavan
f for the doctor of philosophy and
medieval studies Samantha Lily Catz
seal
that's for the doctor of philosophy and
microbiology Don
Chen Lisa Maria
matate
for the doctor of philosophy in
molecular biophysics and
biochemistry William chosen
Chang Vanessa kreer duar
Stacy McGrath
gford Mark Jonathan
landow hunging
Chen
for the doctor of philosophy and
molecular cellular and developmental
biology Aqua Anin
aseri Aaron an
betters
Patrick Michael
cor Jeanie Nicole
Hansen Andrew philli
Hayward
Mary Joy
kju thank
you Andrew Kenneth
Lon Philip
Lis fr
Ling ma ish
hulakan Shannon
Stewart for the master of science Stacy
Alicia
Lawrence
for the doctor of philosophy and
music Esther Marie Morgan
Ellis Mary Danielle Ward
Griffin
for the doctor of philosophy in near
Eastern languages and
civilizations Alicia Eileen Cunningham
Bryant George franois montier
for the doctor of philosophy in
neurobiology Matthew Ryan
Krauss for the doctor of philosophy in
Neuroscience Emily Brinn Einstein
Olivia Maran
far Sarah Martin
Richards Christen Joy rudenga
Nathaniel Jason
Smith Sheree Lenor
wisman
Chingy
for the doctor of philosophy and
nursing Susan J
Boren for the doctor of philosophy and
pharmacology
Nilda Larie Alysia
Velasquez Katherine
Chen for the doctor of philosophy in
philosophy Timothy James Clark
Justin
coup Sandia
tuar Leslie Franchesco wolf
for the master of arts Rebecca Elizabeth
wetz for the doctor of philosophy in
physics Susie
bikin
Christopher Newman
Gilbreth archana
Kamal zir umran
coner
Nicholas Adam
mlock Richard Arthur wall
III Brian James
Walsh
for the master of
philosophy rostislav
bansi for the master of science Stefan
Alexander
elrington for the doctor of philosophy
in political science
Regina and
Bateson Teresa Mia
beon UD
Chandra Nathaniel Terrence
cogley Brian Joseph
freed calber Wallace
Jones Paul David
Kenny David Bower
leau Melissa Daren
Mason Jonah B Hofer
wall Huns Christian
seeler Lucas Todd
Thompson Peter J
bosek
for the doctor of philosophy and
psychology Andrea Lillian
gold Yuna
Kang
Stephanie an
Maddox Mark Isaiah
shesin for the doctor of philosophy in
public
health Hannah Elizabeth
Aram
Heather J Cole
Lewis Jeremy Craig
green
Christopher
Kim Sarah Elizabeth malar Woods
Palace for the master of philosophy
Reuben Chong
weing
Gregory
rli for the master of science tyan
Jong tan
Ma
G
Wong sholi
Wong for the doctor of philosophy in
religious studies Yasir
Kazi Jennifer Suzanne
Lee Natalia Alexandra
meranduk uniton s Moss
John Steven
patard Devin Paul
Singh Aaron Marie
Staley
Andrew Robert Hurst
Thompson y Julia F
Bing David Seth muser
Walker
Aon Glenn
doas for the doctor of philosophy in
Slavic languages and literatures Anna
Valerie
adinan
Margarita
safarian for the master of philosophy
Vadim
Schneider Roman
utkin for the doctor of philosophy and
sociology Elizabeth Butler
Bree Tabitha Lind
Decker
Andrew
Yonker Esther chii
Kim Sylvia favini
metrod
Samuel C
Nelson Michael William
yarro for the master of
philosophy Craig laprice
Holloway
for the doctor of philosophy and Spanish
and
Portuguese Alesia
delant Jennifer Allison
derell Daniel
dooso for the doctor of philosophy and
statistics Taylor Bailey
Arnold
youngl for the master of arts Patrick
James Andrew
Burns Brian Yung Jen
choy
U Olivia Caroline
Mulla ding J
Wong
UA
Wong UA
young yes but
just
okay every year it happens for various
reasons that some students are not able
to sit with their departments and come
forward for their diplomas in the usual
order so now ladies and gentlemen we
award the final degrees which in some
cases may not appear in the
program for the doctor of philosophy and
Mathematics babak
Mami
thank
you
pretty impressive to see all this Talent
up here on the stage uh I'd also like to
congratulate Dean shme for reading all
those
names now we're going to have a little
fun so I'd like to call out each degree
and for the recipient of that degree to
stand and remain standing after which
we'll congratulate everybody again this
is always fun the masters of
arts please
stand Masters of
Science keep keep on
standing
there master of
philosophy
and doctor of
philosophy so graduates keep standing
because we have a little tradition here
and that is we have this opportunity for
you to thank all the families and
friends and supporters who've helped you
achieve the distinction of receiving
your degrees today so I'd like to invite
all our degree recipients to give a
round of applause to everybody who
supported
them
thank you you can be seated
now today we celebrate the
accomplishments of our graduates each of
you has broaden your intellectual
Horizons and acquired skills that will
be useful to you and to society those of
you have done original research have
advanced scholarship and understanding
of the world and for the families and
friends it's important to recognize that
The Graduate students actually do a
large fraction of the research here at
the University so thank you very much we
take great pride in you and your work in
addition to gratification for a job well
done I hope you had plenty of fun while
you were here with us in New Haven
looking back on these years I'm sure you
will find them among the best of your
lives
each graduate should be grateful to
those who made your work possible you've
just recognized your families and
friends here in the hall but let me
acknowledge two other supportes sources
of support first to the generous donors
who contributed to the endowment of Yale
University that has paid for about half
of your
education
and let me thank the everyone in the
room and around the country because the
taxpayers of the United States Finance
the other half of your education and we
appreciate
it the taxpayers have helped support
graduate education through training
grants and through research grants and
individual fellowships that uh members
of the graduating class have held during
their time
here now I'm sure that each of you
graduates realizes that the time that
you've had here to devote to scholarship
has been a privilege but now it is a
responsibility for you to make the world
a better place uh through service in
education research communities
government and other walks of
life individuals with Advanced degrees
have have the power and the knowledge to
change people's lives please take that
responsibility
seriously
congratulations
for
that's